hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to The Binding of Isaac
rebirth the game that a lot of people
have been asking me to play for a long
long time and I've been fervently
ignoring them because I don't know why I
don't like a challenge or something but
I've never played the game before but I
know great many people who have
northernlion for one who is probably on
his 500 billions part the game grumps
inflated they did that it was
entertaining to watch so I'm gonna try
the curious word being try okay
so what this is weirder than I thought
it was so the idea is that it's a
roguelike game that's supposed to be
very challenging and I can already see
that it's gonna be a bit challenging
because the control scheme is a little
wonky I move with the WASD but I also
dead bird protective buddy okey-dokey
then
but I also fire with the arrow keys so I
got to pick what direction I fire that's
gonna hurt on the way through it no pain
no gain
okey-dokey then yay that was worth it I
think I don't know what things are in
this yet so maybe it was I don't know if
my bomb would be able to get through to
those chests I don't even know how to
bomb Wow how do I it worked
was it worth it I got two bombs who's
almost exactly worth it okay can this go
through here oh oh that one needs a key
okay I didn't know that well if I get a
key on this level I guess I'll try to
get that one die you bastard you poop
fragment it's key how perfect is that
it's almost as if it's teaching me as a
game on an almost easy level it was what
it had it okay then it was the chest
with smaller chests in it alright okay
so this game is gonna be a little bit
interesting for me too I
heyyou sake yeah what are you doing why
are you shy
I know I've been through a million
bullet hell she ain't gonna get me back
off there I thought I was going the
wrong way sorry the double keyboard is
messing with my brain I'm like I want to
go two different ways
are they puking or are they crying I'm
not sure which is which
wait no oh that was the boss I didn't
mean to go in the boss I didn't knows
why
all right then stop believin so much
poop okay
[Music]
still in use this die I don't know but
that we're kind of Bomberman corner me
yeah so much poop everywhere oh god I
haven't said that since don't starve why
does he have a butt crack - oh yeah
placenta gross okay so I'm not gonna do
a full playthrough this game for one
reason this game has no end as far as
I've been told I mean considering that
some people are on their 500 something
series of this game episode of this game
I'm gonna guess it doesn't have an end
and this is the rebirth version so it's
a more advanced version which I'm
assuming begins that there's even more
crap and I have no idea what's about so
also I know that there's secrets but I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to tell
where they are so I have right now I'm
just go oh god I thought that was a
butterfly first this guy with no head
okay key yes I need that to open that
door where it needs a key I think
PFF PFF
I got no PFF I don't even have any money
expect me to do with that that's not
worth my hey big guy whoa what you're
doing here you have a sauce sour
disposition okay
well Dallas that was rude okay I know
it's a normal bodily function but a lot
of things in this world are normal
bodily functions that I still don't like
it it's never walking around with your
head cut off that's not it
okay there's something I got a funny
feeling yep
okay I was completely wrong apparently
there are bombs where you can blow up
things such as walls and be able to move
forward but I was very wrong about my
son man let me let me let me cry open
all the piles of poop first because
that's exactly what I'm doing I'm crying
piles of poop open all right I think I'm
gonna like this game already I hope you
guys are liking it because wow okay so
what I'm gonna try to do is I'm gonna
try to get to the end boss which as far
as I know is an end boss I don't know
much else about it
so oh good another punishment chamber my
favorite pull those what a black hearts
mean the black hearts main what well
that was weird what happened is it oh
this is the what this is what Barry was
trying to he was trying to get the
sacrificial thing so if I I do this
there's a chance of my giving something
if I sacrifice my health to it but I
don't know if I want to do that although
two times
I got something on my first try oh look
at me I'm the greatest suck it Barry
suck it hard everybody go tell Barry
tweet at him or something
I don't remember what it's turn Hannah
but you can find it he was trying and
trying and trying to get it I get it on
my first try
whoa I'm doing so good I'm so good at
games
I'm not have any why is this in shadow
that makes me think I was still wrong
okay hey big guy gonna fart some more
sounds really Pleasant the last time we
uh we connected as people Nobby didn't
even get a chance just weird headless
body sin I'm gonna cry to death
what'd I say about me cry my enemies to
death whoa big room oh so they're crying
blood at me because they have no eyes
that's good it's nice to know hey I need
to upgrade my weapon I'm still using the
very basic it's not exactly the best hey
we're here oh yeah go get em party go
get him birdie come on birdie do
something go get him it's gonna give a
cry by shooting wow that bird really got
forget him get him birdy wow he's in his
eye sockets that is gross yeah get him
get him there you go there you go sonny
jim there you go there you go dang go
Jim yeah get up there we go thank you
thank you very much get it
okay hey I'm getting all sorts of
power-ups how can anyone lose at this
game they must be really bad or I'm just
getting really lucky still don't have an
upgraded weapon which is like half of my
problem here come on
see you so long to kill things whoa
just die already let me tell you the sad
story of my life so that you can fall
over really nothing
what is that goopy piece of meat I guess
it's better than the goopy pieces of
poop but come on gross hey just attack
him already you stupid bird I know he
only comes out when I get damaged but
that's not exactly very helpful
lookie I can open up the thing in the
other room yeah I need more keys it's
being very sparing about its key
distribution yeah once again this isn't
exactly something that I need but was
this mystery pill graty then okay I'll
take this have a good day sir good why
how do I use the mystery pill again I
have no idea that was a bum that was not
the right button where are the controls
[Music]
help me at all
yes I'll just go to the boss and spank
his bottom
monstro are you doing there buddy how
you doing there friend I know whoa get
him birdy get the birdies mean to me
call me a big name
god this attack is so and did bird get
him bird good bird okay all right bird
there we go huh bird if you could if you
could you would be so kind would you
kindly mr. there we go
yep okay yeah sorry is gonna be a while
because I I'm literally shooting my
tears at him what are you expected to do
a lot of nothing
I know indigestion of all the blood you
drink really gross burger I can't
imagine anybody having any kind of
trouble with this game no I've never
played before I'm just a natural mouth
shows toothless appeared in the basement
does that mean in this basement who's
that dog food dinner HP up well I'm
getting plenty of HP but that doesn't do
anything to know what is that
I want it damn it oh I got horns
I got nubby little horns thanks for the
black soles buddy you're a friend indeed
okay I'm gonna go now I just left you in
darkness I prefer you I think you'd
prefer that anyway so okay I think I'm
done here no I don't know I don't know
I'm just gonna go down as if I know
what's going on but in reality I really
don't why are they pooping at me kind of
childhood do I lead at least the music
is banging in this place that's cool
that's cool
whoa hello whoa whoa whoa whoa okay oh
it's a revenge heart kills everything in
the room you're gonna give me well that
was rather easy okay I told him what he
wasn't gonna are those butts are those
crawling butts please tell me those are
crawling butts unless they're crawling
Ding Dongs because they might be
crawling ding dongs
okay now I'm really curious are they but
Sir Ding Dongs write in the comments
below but Sir Ding Dongs that make a
great and horrible sitcom at the same
time or Game Show
but but Sir dicks whoa hey friends till
the position
holy crap I love it I got a robo buddy
nice nice
okay so what I'm supposed to spend two
keys unlocking that brick and then
opening that thing all right whatever
okay well this is also good but I don't
have any keys all I've gotten are these
health ups oh it's such a pain by the
way this is completely randomly
generated and the game's 15 bucks for 15
bucks and what could possibly be
literally endless hours of entertainment
not a bad deal not a bad deal you can do
well hours whoa who's envy with a
lizanne v-- zap boom Robo buddy okay
you're not really zapping them I'm gonna
wet him up with my electricity and you
might my things and you zap them with
your electro okay my little buddy does a
lot more damage than I do
this is be honest right now let's see
the combo kind of does work well okay
that's not what I was expecting
it's focused on getting one down okay
just one one at a time don't let it get
too unmanageable cuz that's how you die
that's how you die okay it was weird
is that the only attack City as just
splitting up into little parts cuz if I
can actually handle them then it's not a
big deal okay saying the problem at all
how could anyone have a problem with
this but terrible games and whatnot not
as skilled and/or handsome as me you
know I'm sorry all the fast moderate
fella falls Maciel Oh false modesty
that's exactly what I'm doing right now
bravado that's the where does it go okay
oh is that it
it couldn't have been it something see
cried damn and they won't give me any
secrets want a secrets
so let me go back up this way because
they don't think I've been ha whoa big
guy didn't I kill you guys
however their move what does that's whoa
okay oh no hey now you're a rock star
it's game on go play anyway all right I
think it's dead
oh god the butts the penis I don't know
what they are but the gross gross it
could just be normal slugs but hey whoa
whoa so they do have faces I didn't see
faces before they didn't have face
before
damn it I need a pee so I get a key Oh a
key all right okay
ask and ye shall receive what's in here
Oh a ladder ha that's so I can go back
up I don't have all that much money so I
guess I'll just get this hey I got
another one of these things I'm never
gonna die really I never never we've got
a lot of good stuff
you guys look fun Oh God okay maybe I
will die spiders in my face also a
spider in me cuz I got Oh God
Eze oh they cry that's horrible
was that a robot spider just kill it
already yeah oh why are they glowing
well they have red dots on him yeah
what's that do I want it I want Libra
what does that mean I feel balanced Oh
Khan
I don't get it I don't get it I'm get it
what did it do for me besides to make me
look kind of black and white all right
whatever
oh come on not over yet it couldn't have
been worth it I don't know what this
means
yeah yeah yeah oh oh I got to finish
them off before they get back up again
okay
yeah anymore yeah more of course more
why not more
you never move it whoa hey whoa hey whoa
and I'm done and I don't get any more
rewards gross I just notice there are
maggots crawling on the floor after all
that okay this is this a little more
over here that I gotta explore oh yeah
for me nothing unless there's actually
something there might be actually
something you never know if you okay Wow
some let me just look over where there
might be a something over here nope okay
I'm 0 for 3 on that one good job
markiplier you're a shining example of
what truth and justice serves for the
American public so anyway how did they
get Seven Keys when did I get seven keys
what wait a minute balance did it make
all my items get balanced no reasonable
fly hive you also you how do I use the
pushin whoa okay so don't press the
letter F it'll make you go fullscreen
and to ruin your recording just so we
know about that one when we find out
what's in here well oh all right I
forgot to put out the fire okay did I
know that was gonna hurt me
curse skull cursed cursed balls of steel
yes I guess I'm good okay guide I don't
know I don't know what's going on either
way I'm gonna finish this up in the next
episode I'm going to get all the way to
the end boss of this one and that'll be
the end of binding of issac if you guys
are really enjoying the game let me know
in the comments below after I'm done
with it for tomorrow or not tomorrow but
you know after I'm done with next
episode I'm done with this game let me
know if you want to see it on a live
stream I'll be happy to play it's
practically unlimited unlimited
entertainment fun for the whole family
except where it's horrible so thanks
again everybody and as always what the
hell Oh what was the fires art agony
just I've got a fire magic
kind of weird fire magic is that what
that was
okay so thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
it's so hard that's what she's mother so
big
[Music]